Travis and I want to have a baby
um what was that Court Travis and I want
to have a baby yep Kourtney Kardashian
and Travis Barker are ready to expand
their blended family in a new
full-length trailer for the famous
family's upcoming Hulu series The
Kardashians fans get a sneak peek at the
42 year old's reality star and the 46
year old drummer at the doctor's office
talking about having a little one of
their own Travis and I want to have a
baby put the sample in this cup we'll
take our mics off you don't get the
audio and that that's Travis kissing his
fiance's hand as she lies down on a bed
at the doc's office
I love you
[Music]
of course this isn't a total surprise
because back in February A source told
E.T that court and Trev are so in love
and are open to the idea of having
children together and growing their
family and according to the source the
couple has the full support of their
families who just want them to be happy
I'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens fans of the Kardashians
previous E-Series will recall the push
founder froze her eggs with keeping up
cameras rolling back in 2018. so I've
been thinking about freezing my eggs are
you serious you want another kid what if
I do though I don't know what I want
what if I want a kid in the next 10
years wouldn't you rather have the
insurance like sitting like sitting
there of course all this went down
before she started dating the Blink 182
drummer who would you have a kid with I
don't know I don't need a baby to have
have a baby I have three kids I'm saying
if I am like in love what if I want my
love to come into the world well she
went through with it and the hormones
from the fertility shots led to Courtney
delivering this iconic line I mean I
feel fine I just cry myself to sleep
every night classic
I hope that going through all of this is
worth it because you know I really don't
want to put my body through this again
well from the new trailer looks like it
might have been worth it Travis and I
want to have a baby of course Courtney
shares three kids with her ex Scott
Disick 12 year old mason nine-year-old
Penelope and seven-year-old Reign while
Travis has two kids of his own with his
ex Shayna Moakler 18 year old Landon and
16 year old Alabama and when E.T chatted
with Shayna in February she said she's
cool with her kids appearing on the
Kardashians new show I won't be tuning
in however
um you know I think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
Travis Knight you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
Kardashians are good to my kids you know
that's all that matters to me as a mom
you know as long as they're happy and
then you know that's that's the key as
for Courtney and Travis who got engaged
in October a source recently told ET
that the two are deep in wedding
planning mode quote both Courtney and
Travis are so looking forward to
spending the rest of their lives
together as soul mates
[Music]